hello everyone and welcome to another
game from a most eventful round nine of
the feeding candidates tournament 2022
it's temura java versus hikaru nakamura
java still without a single win face
sikaru these were the standings before
the actual round nine so these are the
standings after round eight if any of
you um uh forgot this so you can see
that rajabov uh has three points but
that's um uh six draws and two losses
and hikaru doing much much better two
wins five draws and only one loss uh so
it would be uh for hikaru if he wins
this he could uh get get closer to the
uh to the leaders uh yani permission
fabiana carwana but rajabov still uh
well of course once the wants to do as
well as he can in the tournament and he
will try his best to win this uh in
their uh first encounter in the first
half of the candidates tournament if you
remember hikaru had the white pieces
sarah java played the berlin defense and
he car won that game very nicely uh
because uh well uh
who whoever lost again
against uh a player playing the berlin
defense as i always say uh so here are a
job of chose e4 and after e5 knight to
f3 knight to c6 and bishop b5 the rue
lopez is on the board hikaru also went
for knight to f6 the berlin defense and
as i always say whoever lost a game
playing the berlin defense so d3 we have
bishop to c5 and now c3 our job goes for
the absolute main line hikaru mixed it
up a little bit with knight beat to d2
in their first game in the first half of
the candidates here's c3 we have castles
castles and now
uh standard uh idea here is just d6 so
continue to develop and strengthen the
center prepare to develop your light
square bishop uh but he car plays d5
here it's a it's a fairly rare move here
but it has been played by pretty much
everyone uh for example magnus cross and
played it against leveling around karana
played it against wesley so carlson also
played it against karjakin uh arunian
played it against mvl uh but there is
also one very special game that nakamura
uh played against the vastly when
nakamura defeated him uh in the 2011
amber blindfold tournament all of those
games uh featured this d5 idea so uh
rajab of uh most likely uh prepared for
this knight v to d2 d captures on e4 we
have d captures on e4 and now pawn to a5
not allowing b4 as that is or well
more often than not a great move by
white if not just outright winning queen
to c2 and now queen to e7 we have a4 now
uh and here comes knight to a7 in a lot
of the games that we mentioned knights
the b8 was played uh and for example
magnus carlsen versus vladimir kramnik
in the louvre in blitz 2017 that ain't
the end that ended in a draw featured
this knight the b8 move uh but here we
have knight day 7 by hikaru and it is
still not a new game but we are getting
very very close to that so putting
pressure on the bishop
bishop back to e2 and now just repeating
knight to c6 asking rajabo do you have
anything better knight to b3 attacking
the bishop and the bishop to a7
now interestingly bishop to b6 is the
absolute best move here or you could
consider d6 or b6 but definitely not
bishop to a6 and maybe that hikaru
played
and this was played this year uh a month
ago in the in the bundesliga the game
ended in a draw between yen suv and
mitwald and stefan zilka but after
bishop the a6 there is a problem and the
java immediately points to the problem
by playing bishop to b5 so it's like
they're repeating moves but not really
because now with hikaru's bishop on a7
and bishop to b5 comes with tempo we're
just threatening to
capture the knight and after pawn
captures we're going to win the a5 pawn
the bishop on a7 is blocking the rook's
defense of the pawn on a5 so here hikaru
should just
admit that the bishop does not belong on
a7 and waste another move with bishop to
b6 then the game continues and everyone
is happy but like a true saiyan now of
course hikaru has his pride and he goes
for bishop to g4 and this is usually the
start of everyone's downfall so now
bishop captures in c6 bishop captures an
f3 and a java plays the g captures on f3
b captures in c6 and now he grabs a pawn
knight captures an a5 and it's not just
that you grab the pawn but
also white just has a past a pawn and
that's um
that's a pretty big deal so queen to e6
uh and now queen to e2 now you have to
set up a bit of a defense perimeter here
knight stage 5 to f4 could be a bit a
bit of a problem the bishop also is
looking very nice here uh so knight's
the h5 you could also just win the pawn
right back with bishop captures and real
captures an a5 but this is a monster
bishop you don't want to trade it for
for you know just winning back your pawn
so knight's the h5 and now pawn to b4
now rajabov starts marching those pawns
forward king the h8 as you know rajabo
is playing king to h1 and the rooks are
coming to the g file uh and now king to
h1 we have h6 by hikaru now comes rook
to g1 and ponte f5 uh going for a
breakthrough here on the king's side and
now arajabov has to
figure out how to go about this does he
somehow play a rogue g2 maybe develops
the bishop gets the other rook into the
game if he wants to play for some sort
of an attack or does he play rook to g2
uh with some other idea but also very
interesting was he captures an e5 on f5
i'm just gonna mention this because
after rook captures bishop e3
uh what can what can black play here for
example if knight to f4 we play queen c4
off for a queen trade we're attacking
the c6 pawn we're putting pressure on
the knight so everything is looking
great for white um
it will be very hard for for hikaru to
defend this but okay rajabo has a
different idea he plays rook to g2 f
captures an e4 and now queen captures an
e4 and this is a very important capture
for example if you undouble your pawns
then queen h3
is a problem for for white
now rook to f3 is coming you're going to
double rook on the f file and you know
with all of the this pressure it's not
going to be
all that possible for white to survive
this attack so here queen captures an e4
this is a must for for the job of and
then now comes rook to f6
uh this is uh now if you go for queen to
h3 now which of course is possible then
queen g4 and now you kind of have to
trade queens you can do it with queen
captures on f3 captures captures and now
we play knight captures on c6 and while
this is playable it seems like it's uh
too much to give white rook captures and
c3 knight captures on a7 rook captures
now pawn to a5 you start pushing those
pawns forward the bishop is coming to e3
you will have more support for the
pushing and it's very unlikely black can
stop this so hikaru tries rook to f6
instead of this now adds more support to
the to the c6 pawn and now maybe you can
double up on the f file
but now bishop to e3 bishop captures an
e3 f captures and queen to d5 now
offering a queen trade and here um we
even have a photo of this moment so if
you guys want to enjoy it a little bit
there we have it he carl played queen to
d5 and he went into his staring mode
and rajab is weighing the situation
uh so you can see that it's an
incredibly intense moment hikaru knows
uh java is better due to the past a pawn
but he will of course
try try to hold on uh if he could avoid
trading queens and keep this position
then it'd be maybe uh good for hikaru
because he did open up rajabos king but
it is simply not possible queen to g4 by
rajabov he wants to trade queens but on
his terms now the knight is hanging here
so just queen captures an f3 pretty much
the only movie if you don't want to play
queen to f7 uh queen captures on f3 rook
captures attacking the pawn here and
just rook to e2 defending and now if you
look at the possession the material is
equal but it's the past a pawn that will
pose problems for hikaru so hikaru plays
c5 he wants to get rid of his double c
pawn and knight to c6 now and here he
again rushed it a little bit he played c
captures on b4 and pretty much uh uh
simplified uh
the the position too much for for
with with knight to f6 you are still in
the game because it's very hard to
advance those pawns for example if b5
knight comes to d5 now you're attacking
this point you're attacking this pawn
and the black is uh
fighting uh once again but here after c
captures on b4 now rajabov can just push
those pawns so c captures we have rook
to f6 by hikaru attacking the knight and
now b5 the knight nicely defended here
on the outpost rook to d6 uh and now we
have pawn to a5 so just continuing to
push the pawn not trying to waste time
grabbing material knight to f6 and now
pawn to a6 we have knights to d7
uh and pawn to a7 so beautifully played
the pawn nicely defended here by both
the knight and the rook king to g8 and
now rook to c2 we have king to f7 now
comes knight to b4 putting pressure on
the c7 pawn so c5 hikaru has to give it
up somehow he decides to give it up this
way b captures on c6 now getting another
pass pawn knight to b6 and pawn to e4
now we have knights the c8 trying to
grab the a7 pawn but just rook c to a2
everything is nicely defended king to e6
we have rook to a6 and now rook to d4 we
have knight to d5 uh now going for
knight to c7 check which would win the
rook so king to d6 but now knight to b6
and he was in this position on
41 after both players have reached time
control
that hikaru nakamura resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so the rook is attacked and once
you capture the knight as you can save
the rook uh we're just gonna capture
here and it doesn't matter what you play
of king c7 we just force the king to
capture the pawn king captures we offer
a rook trait and that's it you either
trade and we bring a queen into the game
or you have to give up the rook here for
the pawn now we're upper full rook of
course completely winning
so incredible incredible game that
really shows uh the the character of
chess players not just elite chess
players but of every chess player
because here in this moment where hikaru
could have
played it back after knight to b3 and
bishop to a7 this bishop to b5 move is
is incredibly annoying because you
realize that the bishop does not belong
here but there is no chess player in the
world that would admit this and you know
waste another move with bishop to b6 and
that's just not how a chess player's
mind works like uh even even if i had
this position i would never
uh waste a move uh you know
uh i i would also place something at
least you know just just try and you
know uh
live in the illusion that uh i don't
have to waste the move that you know
what i've played is actually very much
playable uh but uh it's just um you know
the the reality is just very different
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it never uh you know be afraid
to to waste a move if it improves your
position uh you know you're gonna lose
uh
not so many games so you know maybe
maybe another this advice can help you
in your future games uh i would like to
thank steven mcneill b
is the one daniel schmidt ultimate poker
coaching and muhammad al-saban for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and we are
going to show the standings after round
nine but uh after we check out a few
more games uh see you soon